this is the only place in san francisco
you can see bison
this is the best spot to view the golden
gate bridge
[Applause]
this is one of the oldest gay bars in
the city cheers
but it all starts here
at the concierge desk
of the fairmont san
francisco i'm tom wolf
and i'm america's first concierge
i was very lucky because my parents
loved to go out so i was constantly
seeing
the world of hospitality world of the
restaurants the world of sophistication
and that's kind of where the seed was
planted shall we say
my first hotel job was working in
washington dc and i then went to london
and the general manager asked me have
you got a morning suit
luckily i knew what a morning suit was
and i said of course mr schwenter i do
my next port of call would be paris i
managed to get a job at a very luxurious
hotel right on the champs-elysees and i
learned many lessons
i made my way back to the united states
where i found myself in san francisco
[Music]
i started as the concierge at the
fairmont in 1974.
the fairmont hotel occupies an entire
square block the main building opened in
1907 one year to the day after the great
fire
if these walls could whisper
what stories they would tell
a secret door
that could be used for a discreet exit
the tonga room
was once the fairmont swimming pool
if you can think of somebody important
they were here whether they were from
the world of hollywood
or the world of politics pretty much
every president has stayed here at one
time or another and we had the first
person to break the color barrier in the
venetian room where an entertainer
of color would be able to stay at the
same place where they performed the
fairmont philosophy has always been the
best kind of guest you can hope for is a
repeat guest
when i'm out and about walking to this
very day
i'm still exploring
and i find these little streets that i
haven't been down or i find a shop that
i've not been in
and i take the time to go in and say
hello and introduce myself
it's a constant learning experience and
the minute you stop learning well you
might as well stop working
[Music]
you